ja mir geht es da noch mal um die kinder
und vor allen dingen um die schulen wir
haben ja zu beginn der pandemie relativ
wenig daten gehabt über die pandemie das
hat sich im wesentlichen auch nicht
geändert deshalb tut man sich
wahrscheinlich auch mit der evaluierung
der maßnahmen so schwer was wir aber von
anfang an schon wussten und diejenigen
die guten menschenverstand haben die
konnten das auch ohne studien sehr
schnell herausfinden dass die schließung
von kitas und von schulen von
spielplätzen der wegfall von sport- und
freizeitmöglichkeiten der kontaktverbot
für kinder dass das natürlich immense
ganz ganz schreckliche und schlimme
auswirkungen auf unsere kinder und
jugendlichen haben würde wer diesen
menschenverstand nicht besitzt er konnte
sie gerne auch die vielen studien zu
hilfe nehmen da gab es ja
unterschiedlichste von die kopf die
studie aus dem universitätsklinikum
hamburg eppendorf oder die leipziger
studie oder jetzt kürzlich im dak report
die haben alle gezeigt dass die
psychischen probleme von kindern und
jugendlichen massiv zugenommen haben
essstörungen depressionen massive
gewichtszunahme also wirklich massive
probleme die unsere kinder gehabt haben
und wir können bis heute nicht
nachweisen dass schulschließungen
irgendwie geholfen hätte den kindern im
sinne der pandemie bekämpfung der hilfe
vor dem virus
etwas gutes zu tun kinder sind keine
pandemie treiber sie haben auch nicht
unter den virus gelitten aber es wird
ganz sicher wissen dass sie eben unter
den massnahmen gelitten haben und
deswegen kann ich nur jedem der auch nur
irgendwie darüber nachdenkt im herbst
wieder solche drastischen maßnahmen zu
ersinnen nur sagen hände weg von unseren
kinder wird auf unsere kinder das nie
wieder antun es muss eine garantie geben
für einen präsenzunterricht für offene
kitas und offene schulen die kinder die
damals schon schwer hatten die sind so
weit zurückgefallen und das dürfen wir
unseren kindern die wieder anschauen
also wenn ich mir anschaue dass wir
felder ich habe da gerade ein bild wie
die zweijährige enkeltochter von meinem
mann wie das kind
freudestrahlend angerannt kommt und sie
darf aber in europa nicht umarmen und
nicht über erwecken so was passiert mit
so einem kind wenn die die das ist ja
ein sie hat dieses bedürfnis den opa sie
ist voller liebe zu umarmen das darfst
du nicht ja was passiert was passiert
hat da passiert ganz viel da das ist
doch wie können diese menschen noch
überhaupt soziale kontakte später
aufbauen wie wie werden die groß gerade
in diesen jungen jahren wie wir werden
die große furchtbar das ist entsetzlich
und auch dieses dieses unverständnis und
diese enttäuschung ist die unsicherheit
das jetzt nicht auf den opa zu darf ja
das bleibt das blei das bleibt absolut
wenn dieser klaren sind sie kennen ja
gar nichts anderes mehr sind ja
aufzuwachsen und dann haben sie alle
schon das handy als wieder nur noch über
handy dann bald also herr bruder sehen
auch ein enkelkind wie haben sie das
gehandhabt in der pandemie und kann es
sein durch laute aber dass wir bald
wieder die schulglocken habe ich habe es
keine jahren haben unsere tochter und
ihr mann haben das wunderbar gerannt
haben ich glaube das kind ist ziemlich
normal geworden das kind auch sehen ja
ja ja das kind das normal und gut drauf
es kommt nach mir das rennen habe ich
mache ich mir keine sorgen aber ich muss
noch 1
dagegen sagen wir reden ja über
deutschland aber die situation die sie
beschreiben ist keine deutsche
spezialität dieser pandemie und der
umgang mit der pandemie hat dieser
gesellschaften atomisiert einer schweren
vielleicht werde ich schon nicht
geschlossen schweden hat die schule
nicht geschlossen ist dann hat die
schule nicht geschlossen aber im großen
und ganzen war ganz europa unter einem
unglaublichen aber deutschland ist auf
platz 1 der härtesten kroner maßnahmen
wir haben es wirklich geschafft der
spitzenreiter das kann schnell zahlen
unglaublicher die als am längsten
durchgezogen die lok wir die besten sein
soll ich bitte sie in mainz die besten
wieder
damit ja aber dann arbeiten von zehn
jahren sagen nein dieser gesellschaft
hat deswegen ein gestörtes verhältnis zu
kindern weil sie selber vollkommen
infantil ist dieser gesellschaft schon
zigmal nur drei tage rtl oder ard die
totale infantilisierung und sie haben ja
nicht nur die kinder der schwierigen
haushalten kommen sie haben diese ganze
verwahrlosten mittelstands blase die
jeden freitag für freude für future auf
die straßen geht ich habe mich in die
mühle um gesehen und ich war paar mal
versucht einem kind zu leben wenn es mir
zum beispiel sagte es geht nicht mehr
zur schule weil die welt geht sowieso
unter und das ist mein bruder da können
sie ja nicht auf ein gerät
hans das kinderspiel ja und dass ein
gerät ja ja man muss dem kind eine
zweite chance geben ja genau das habe
ich auch gemacht ich hab ja auch nicht
zugeschlagen ich sage ich entdeckte
furchtbare abgründe in mir angesichts
dieser rotzlöffel die mehr erklären wie
die welt funktioniert und sie haben eine
wissen sie eine eine vergöttlichung von
kindergärten ich meine wenn ich kinder
sehe mit dem plakat wir haben keine plan
wir haben kein planet b aber wir konnten
ja wenigstens noch demonstrieren auf die
straßen gehen wenn wir jetzt frau zu
denen auch ein mit den kinder
schließlich muss auch sein mittel der
mittelstand kindern einfach angst hat
kommen sehen ob die auswirkung haben sie
arbeiten die auswertung trotzdem muss
ich noch mal einen haken was haben sie
gedacht die werden wir später sehen hier
also haben die mitarbeiterin da sagte
mir der dreijährige sagt mama bald darf
ich maske tragen oder erster london war
vorbei schule ging wieder an ein kind
hatte kronen die mutter kann auf die
brillante idee ich könnte ja mein handy
hindernisse am unterricht teilnehmen
kann das geht in deutschland dann wegen
datenschutz wieder nicht also mal
sondern eine lustige anekdoten und das
ist halt schwierig und was das an
spätfolgen hat kein baby schwimmen wenn
man sich das mal vorstellen da schon
babys erwartet am 26 die waren total
isoliert über zwei jahre aber das wird
spätfolgen haben wir wir wissen noch gar
nicht was das alles beim menschen
psychologisch aus wird weil das war halt
glück dass er sagt ich gehöre sozusagen
auch dazu denn starkes mindset hat und
sich durchsetzen kann aber davon gibt es
halt leider nicht so viele menschen die
eine andere unterstützung brauchen und
die haben wir echt auch in der zeit
später dass er
glücklich ist auch eine starke
persönlichkeit wahrscheinlich überhaupt
das ja auch andere fand sich der runde
warum haben sie zum beispiel ein starker
persönlichkeit nichts gegen die kinder
nichts für die kinder während der
schulschließung getan ich frage mich
schon manchmal da lobt man das mindset
die starke persönlichkeit aber als die
kinder nicht mehr in schulen durften
haben wir alle auch nichts gemacht oder
doch wer mit kinder lachen schon
aktionen gefahren und haben dagegen was
getan hast da sind viele menschen
unterwegs gewesen aber sie sehen ja
selber das ist ja das schwierige wir
haben ja kaum noch jemand das ist auch
das was sie sagen infantil dass ich in
deutschland traut was zu sagen du musst
ja schon wenn eine meinung hat sie auch
öffentlich äußerst ja schon angst haben
denn deswegen find ich auch versucht
sich so klasse mit ihrem buch das ich
einfach sagen ich bin da ausgestiegen
weil ich kein bock mehr drauf hatte aber
wer traut sich das zu machen wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir angepasst sind ja
nicht auffallen ja und das macht es so
schwierig denn wie viele harald
glööckler als beispiel auch als nur als
kunstfigur wie er selber sagt als
künstler gibt es denn die sie auch
trauen was zu sagen glauben sie nicht
dass wenn noch mal ich schon geschlossen
werden seien für die kinder müssten alle
erwachsen hat die strafe ist totaler
bereit nochmal durch lasst mich zur
arbeit geht sind aber wieder da das sind
die menschen die jede woche zwei stunden
39 am tag fernsehschauen ja die in der
pandemie extrem zugenommen haben jeder
vierte deutsche ist übergewichtig also
und das ist ja die behäbigkeit die sich
in allen gesellschaftsbereichen
darstellt ob in den schulen ob bei den
lehrern ob bei mittelschicht ob bei
unternehmern also müssen auch mal
unternehmer sehen es gibt ja nicht nur
die guten unternehmen es gibt ja auch
die in die keinen guten lohn zahlen
damit unsere tiefer stehende land und es
geht so gut habe ich ja eine
streitschrift geschrieben um
12 34 wichtig als dass sie sehen das
stimmt nicht
übergewichtig benutzen
selbst stellen und das ist sie waren
lange in der politik wie wahrscheinlich
ist es denn das nochmal auf die
bevölkerung schulschließung kommen
also ich kann es mir beim besten willen
nicht vorstellen wie man so irre sein
kann dass man bei der jetzigen
virusvariante bei all dem was man ja
schon weiß über das virus was man also
tun kann um die verbreitung zu
verhindern bei all den maßnahmen die wir
anwenden können dass man und bei dem
wissen darüber wie schlimm und wie
schädlich die schulschließung war das
noch irgendjemand überhaupt auf diesen
absurden gedanken kommen kann nochmals
schulen zu schlimm ist die politik sich
entschuldigen
ja aber nicht nur dafür ja da ist mit
glaube da hatte der damalige
bundesgesundheitsminister recht dass es
da einiges geben wird für das man sich
wenn sie verzeihen sollten aber die
entschuldigung zum beispiel von frau
merkel kam er nicht jetzt zum beispiel
einen großen geben ja und das ist mir
ehrlich gesagt am ende auch egal ich
möchte einfach dass es den kindern
besser geht und ich möchte alles dafür
tun dass wir das aufholen können was da
schiefgelaufen ist das wird ein riesen
kraftakt und dass wir vor allen dingen
in der zukunft und darum geht es vor
allen dingen nicht die gleichen fehler
machen um noch weitere schüler
generationen wirklich abzuhängen und in
den abgrund zu schicken eher glücklich
oder mit die kinder jetzt vernünftig
aufwachsen müssen erwachsenen dann
vielleicht vorbild sein und selber auch
keine masken mittragen die normalität
einkehren lassen
so einfach ist das nicht es ist ja nicht
jetzt nur die maske sind ganz viele
faktoren nein wir müssen
in wege vorzeigen und wir müssen ihnen
möglichkeiten bieten und damit sie aus
ihrem aus ihrer welt aus ihren
tretbooten aus ihrem karussell
rauskommen das ist das wichtigste
erstmal ja und da sehe ich im moment
halt kein kein fortschritt da sind wir
schon wieder so weit zurückgefallen und
deshalb möchte ich da habe ich auch
immer wieder stark machen und bringt das
thema an und und rede auch darüber nicht
nur reden natürlich suchen auch dinge zu
tun aber
man muss jetzt auch immer wieder
ansprechen weil es ist jetzt so
kinderarmut denn man immer in afrika ja
da gibt es auch aber wir haben wir auch
hier in deutschland ja ja wir haben sie
auch hier in deutschland die kinder
diesen als arm bezeichnen haben eltern
die haben im fernsehen die haben genug
geld für tabak und alkohol ich gucke ja
rtl 2 regelmäßig ich bin gut informiert
und ich kann noch mal sagen es ist nicht
die frage der materiellen ausstattung
nein aber auch aber möchte ich durch die
dass das kind muss so eine möglichkeit
haben dass es denn wenn es bei soliden
zu hause lebt und da ist alles gewalt
hätte sich irgendwo denn tagsüber
vielleicht irgendwo anders hin kann aber
was soll's hingehen war ja und deshalb
sind zur einrichtungen wichtigen
einrichtung
der allmacht des staates
jedes kind doch irgendwie die chance
haben muss einen zugang zur bildung zu
bekommen sein leben auf die reihe songs
anlegen ich bin doch da okay geht ja gar
nicht darum dass das kind das ich
verneinen will dass die
elternverantwortung haben oder ist der
stadt alles regeln kann aber statt kann
etwas tun und er hat ein vernünftiges
bildungssystem bereitzustellen was dann
auch offen ist ja um sie als politikerin
hassen sie nicht seit ich bin zu kümmern
ich sagte sie als politikerin hatten
gezeigt dass es auch in zukunft im
selben verstanden aber sie haben nichts
dazu gesagt ein kleines sie haben recht
herr brunner wenn wir ganz leicht
gewesen ja ich glaube ich hatte im
parlament wie keine andere glaube ich
für dieses thema immer der geworben und
die als oppositionsabgeordnete die
regierung der immer wieder vor mir her
getragen es hat mich feldmann noch mehr
messen müssen aber ich glaube ich habe
da wäre mir auch selbst als die
buchhalter aber ich habe ja trotzdem
nicht auf mich fiel er noch einmal
einzusetzen weil das beschäftigt mich ja
auch nach der politik war